for most of the last decade i have spent
every sunday of the football season
sitting elbow to elbow with rodney
harrison fortunately he has only struck
me
i don't know a handful of times really i
mean really you've only really got me a
couple of times where i was like man i
can only imagine how it felt when rodney
harrison brought the full force of his
ability on a football field but rodney
it's been a strange off-season i don't
know what this season's going to look
like but i have a feeling however it
plays out we're not gonna be sitting out
about elbow for a while and i'm gonna
miss that as much as anything
yeah that's one of the toughest parts
mike um with with everything that's
going on and not being able to travel
and be in studio with you guys heck i'm
sitting back last night talking to my
wife just sitting there thinking like
how the heck are we going to even play
football if you think about the nfl and
they say that
the best interest of the players is to
be safe and you're doing everything to
protect the players i just don't know
how you put the players back on the
football field with this virus and not
having a vaccine for it yeah rodney one
of the things that was jarring to me
when the protocols came out a few weeks
ago the league was putting together for
all of the things they need to do in the
facility and in the locker room and on
the sideline keeping everyone separate
well at some point you're going to cross
that thick white line and you're onto
the field it's going to be 22 guys in a
scrum i can't reconcile that and i think
players are starting to realize as we
get closer and closer to the start of
training camp on july 28th
it's not going to be the easiest thing
to do
if you're obsessed with keeping everyone
apart until it's time to practice or
play but then when you practice or play
you can't keep them apart well
everything the cdc has said talked about
six feet away making sure you wear your
mask and making sure that you stay
inside the house guess what football you
have to you have to breathe on people
you have to tackle people you spit on
people um guys have cuts guys cough out
there you can't tell me if i have two or
three kids at home or an elderly parent
that lives with me that i'm gonna be
comfortable going out there practicing
entire week not knowing what the young
guys not knowing what the old guys are
going to do after practice going to
restaurants and things like that i'm not
going to be coming i'm not going to feel
comfortable coming home um to my family
when i have kids and things like that
it's just i don't know how we're going
to have a season bottom line mike i just
i don't know how they're going to do it
and rodney as you say that
you know i'm reminded there's been a
sense for the past few months that when
it comes down to it football players
won't worry about that on the list of
things that they need to be concerned
about on the football field possibly
catching the corona virus isn't even in
the top ten you've got far more
immediate risks that you take but i'm
starting to get the sense that players
are are feeling the way that you just
explained it that they're not just
football robots that just have to play
have to play have to play football and
throw everything else aside i think a
lot of players are taking a more
responsible view of this that even if it
doesn't affect me even if it doesn't
sicken me even if it doesn't kill me
this act of being on the football field
is potentially contributing
to the spread of a virus that endangers
vulnerable people whether they're in
your family whether they're not in your
family and i sense a lot of players are
starting to at least pause and and look
at the broader picture of whether or not
this can can make sense until we do get
to the point that we get it under
control well the big thing that you know
no one's really talking about is you
know a lot of these players the ones
that need the money that actually need
to check a lot of those guys they're
going to want to play if i needed the
money i'm like hey put me on the
football field i don't care what i have
to do in order to get that check but the
game has changed these these guys are
getting paid so much money they don't
have to sit they don't have to go on a
football field because they're making
tens and tens of millions of dollars and
and for me mike if i was one of those
players even if i'm making a lot of
money i would not want to go out there
man it's just it's just so many unknowns
and and think about the anxiety levels
it's so much to worry about trying to
stop patrick mahomes how do you fend the
tight end how do you stop tyree kill but
you can't even focus on those things
because you're focused on your health
you're looking around the locker room
you walk in the locker room you're very
cautious if a guy coughs you're looking
at him strange so already your attention
has been taken away on the things that
you need to focus on and i just don't
know how you comfortably you know like
tom brady he's out there practicing he
says the only thing you fear is fear
itself but yeah you can say that tom
because you're probably the healthiest
guy in the national football league but
for most players they don't have the
type of strict diet the type of strict
regimen that he has so to me it's going
to be wide open season you're going to
see everyone catching this virus and
rodney you raised an excellent point
that i hadn't previously considered we
hear all the time about distractions in
the locker room things that take you
away from your focus things that keep
you from doing your job as bill
belichick wants his players to do this
is the ultimate distraction this is the
ultimate disruption to the routine of a
football team and and even beyond the
mechanical disruption keeping apart
wearing masks having the locker room
spread out as you said and i think you
nailed it you're going to be worried
about it you're going to be thinking
about you're going to be carrying that
burden around
when you otherwise would be fully
focused on your craft and i think it's
going to keep it
uh it's going to make it more difficult
for guys to be fully focused on their
craft because part of their brain is
constantly going to be thinking about am
i going to get it if i get it who in my
family is going to get it how long will
i have it until i know i have it what's
it going to do to me what's it going to
do to others how do i avoid it all that
stuff spinning around is just chewing up
space
that otherwise would be focused on
being the best football player you can
be and think about this mike think about
the coaches in our league yeah we have a
lot of young head coaches but we still
have a lot of older coaches in their in
their you know 50s in their 60s trying
to stay healthy so my concern is not
just for the players who are young and
strong and 20 something years old but
i'm looking at those coaches they're in
their 50s in their 60s you know and it's
just it's it'll be devastating to all
you cannot tell me and i have a high
school junior i have my son as a junior
in high school and i'm taking them back
and forth to workouts and i see all the
social distances well eventually that's
got to go away what's changed in within
the last three and a half four months
since we've seen this pandemic what's
changed mike we don't have a vaccine all
all we're basically seeing out here in
atlanta georgia is people saying screw
it i'm gonna go out there i'm gonna do
whatever i want i'm gonna go to bars i'm
gonna play i'm gonna i'm gonna do
whatever i wanna do i'm gonna go to the
malls i'm going to the store the grocery
store i'm gonna just live my life as
normal and you see the numbers across
the nation just continuously going up
mike
and rodney i didn't expect there to be a
vaccine anytime this year but what i did
expect by august or september
reliable testing quick testing basically
a little room that you go into before
you ever get into the team facility
where you get your mouth swab or you get
your finger pricked and you know within
five or ten minutes whether or not
you're positive and you get tested
before you ever go in maybe you get
tested on the way out in the event that
you've developed from negative to
positive while you've been at work for
12 hours and
they're constantly monitoring and
constantly testing and constantly aware
of who's negative and who's positive
whoever positive gets quarantined but i
feel like we're not going to be there i
thought we were going to be there but if
you don't have the ability to test guys
every single day if you don't have that
peace of mind that everybody who is in
that locker room everybody who's in that
facility has tested negative before they
got through the door that contributes to
what you were saying earlier you're just
going to be worried about it and then
eventually you got to go out on the
practice field eventually you got to go
out and do a game situation and you
don't know a damn thing about what other
teams are doing to ensure that their
guys are negative as well
and like anything else once a bug gets
into the locker room it's a petri dish
it's going to spread like wildfire and i
don't have the confidence that i thought
i'd have at this point that that they're
going to have that under control yeah
and competitively it's it's an unfair
advantage i mean if atlanta's playing
against tampa bay and matt ryan comes
down with coronavirus then guess what
the falcons probably won't have a chance
of even beating the tampa bay buccaneers
i just don't know with everything that's
going on uncertainty um the players the
paranoia the anxiety the risk you're not
if you're international football league
if you're college even if you're high
school or grade school you're not doing
what's in the best interest of these
young men putting them back out on the
foot on the football field and we don't
know what's going to happen to them and
before it was just african-americans and
older people i'm getting it now we're
seeing young people get it i mean young
people all across the country get this
virus
and the thing is rodney at the lower
levels of football the money isn't there
to justify even trying the higher we go
on the ladder college and pro especially
the nfl level the money from the tv
contracts is so significant that i feel
like they're determined to find a way to
make it happen and if it means half the
team is quarantined for three weeks and
we got to find replacements so be
remember in 1987 hey they had no qualms
about going out and getting 28 teams
replacement players when the players
went on strike and i think that's part
of what the owners will be willing to do
which i think introduces a whole new set
of factors when you're considering that
all of a sudden your 35 million dollar
your quarterback is being protected by a
guy that just scraped off of a couch who
hasn't played in three years because
they're down that far on the list of
available free agents but i feel like
that's what they're gonna do that
there's always gonna be a guy out there
who'll say yes i'll play sign me up and
you're gonna have a huge difference
potentially between the best players and
the worst players who are on the field
at a given time that introduces a
different level of risk absolutely i
almost was just sitting here thinking as
you were talking maybe what you do is
instead of having a 16 week season or 17
week season maybe shorten it
maybe shorten the season to 10 or 11
games so therefore you alleviate a lot
of the risks i mean it's still going to
be risks out there in 10 games but not
16 games you know and and maybe that's a
remedy but i still don't think that's
gonna even work because we don't have a
vaccine these guys are still coming to
close on proximity with one another
they're still tackling each other and
think about it too if i'm a db and i'm
known to kind of cover if i see a
running back coming up the middle of the
field i'm not going to want to hit him
i'm not going to want to touch him
because i'm afraid that with all that
sweat and blood coming off of him i'm
like i'm not going to hit this guy i'm
just going to let him go so it just
raises so many questions mike
yeah i agree with you completely and one
of the biggest problems as you mentioned
people just act like they don't care
like it's not a thing and it's bile
appearance is worse now than it was when
we shut the whole country down in march
but the attitude is so be it i'm going
to live my life and meanwhile the
numbers keep going up and up and some of
these players are going to have to go
into
cities and states where the numbers are
skyrocketing and i think we are i
thought there would be very few players
who tap out who say i'm just not doing
it this year i think it's going to be
more than i originally believed and i
won't be surprised if if plenty of guys
ultimately say especially the guys who
have made a lot of money don't need that
extra money and are willing to forego a
season of potentially significant money
to conscientiously decide i'm not doing
it this year i'll be back in 2021 i
think it's going to be a bigger number
than i ever would have imagined i think
so too because like i said before the
game has changed these players are
making so much money and now they're at
a point where
they can come out they can speak out see
it's like when i when i came in the
league when i was say if i was a safety
and i was making a million or two
million bucks these guys are making 10
12 14 million bucks a year so it's not
like they have to play you know what i
mean they have so much money in the bank
they have so much um revenue and finance
and you know a lot of these guys have
done well with their money they don't
have to be feel like they're forced to
come back on the football field
well rodney i i thought of you on sunday
night when i saw that cam newton had
signed with the patriots it's a similar
approach to what happened with you you
establish your career as a star player
with one team that team decides to move
on
and in comes bill belichick recognizing
that there's still a ton of ability a
ton of talent and plenty of ways that a
great player can help a team stay great
uh
what what was your reaction
oh i loved it i i loved it i loved it
mike because on may 28th i talked to i
did an interview with rich eisen
and he asked me the same question about
um cam newton i said i was very
disappointed in the patriots for not
even pursuing cam newton how could you
not pursue a guy that has played been
the mvp played in the super bowl a guy
that's motivated this is a bill
belichick type guy and he goes get guys
that are disgruntled guys that are
motivated guys that really um
you know felt like they've been treated
wrong by the previous organization you
know cam newton is a perfect and then
cam comes in he can he can um challenge
the young guy jared stenham he can you
know he can teach him a few things but
also think about this josh mcdaniels
outside of tim tebow he has not had a
guy like to um cam newton cam is big he
puts a lot of pressure on the defense
now lamar jackson just won the mvp as a
scrambling quarterback cam newton brings
that threat at six five 255 pounds i
mean it's a big dude and think about it
if i'm stefan gilmore if i'm one of the
mccourty brothers i had a glimmer just a
glimmer of hope with jared stenham now i
know we can win a super bowl now i know
we can get back in the afc championship
because i think josh mcdaniels he's
going to adjust a lot of different
things for cam
and the key is whether or not cam
newton's healthy but let's assume for
these purposes that he is i think where
cam
makes a difference for that new england
offense and it's one of the reasons i
think that we've seen mobile
quarterbacks have success against the
new england defense you've got the play
that gets called and if the defense
matches it well enough the play that
gets called isn't going anywhere well
when you have a guy with cam skill sets
he can make up something on the fly and
maybe those defensive players aren't
aren't good enough to keep up with
whatever cam tries to do if the walls
close in and he's got to improvise and
that's what we've seen him do that's
what we've seen some of today's great
quarterbacks do there's a lot of
quarterbacks out there that can't do
that that if if it doesn't work if if
the defense gets right and the play
doesn't work it's over cam can extend
that and make things happen and that's
an element that really the patriots
haven't had with tom brady he he does a
great job running the play that's called
but he's never been a guy who can make
chicken salad in one of those situations
where everything falls apart he's just
got a he's just he's got to throw it
away or he's got to just take the sack
and move on to the next play cam can can
make something happen that makes the
offense even more dangerous you know cam
is at his very best we saw in carolina
mike when they were able to establish
the run and that's what the patrons like
to do as much as they try to undress
everything and try to
hide it as though their passing team the
the one thing that belichick always
talks about is establishing the run we
have to control the line of scrimmage if
they're able to run the football use
play action pass get cam into the quick
passing game to avoid hits belichick's
going to emphasize cam we need you to
slide we need you to get down we don't
need your tough guy we already know that
you're a tough guy sly get down we need
to see you for the next play i think
those all those things kind of come into
play look at josh mcdaniels i mean he
should be happy he should be the
happiest man because now he has a talent
that he's never had before and he gets a
guy like kim is hungry and let me tell
you this mike when you play nine years
in one particular organization and
someone gives you an opportunity coach
belichick gave him an opportunity just
like he gave me an opportunity you don't
forget that you don't forget that
cam's made over a hundred million
dollars in his career the money will
come later he's not worried about that
he wants an opportunity to go out there
and play and i'll tell you this he's
fighting for his career kim is and he
understands that if you can't beat jared
stenham out then cam newton is going to
be a career back up if you cannot beat
jared stenham out for the starting job
of new england patriots quarterback
you're going to be a career backup so
cam is not only playing for a contract
he's playing for his career
i sense some of that same passion that
you would have had back when you joined
the patriots after the charges cut you
bill belichick gave you that chance you
flourished in that system but there's a
huge difference between rodney harrison
and cam newton cam newton's always been
the face of the team cam newton's been
that giant personality what advice would
you have for him walking into a locker
room where it's clear that they don't
want anyone to be the face of the team
they don't want anyone to have the
personality that sucks all the oxygen
out of the room that you're just one of
the guys and the messages do your job
well i think all of us all the guys that
have come in i think when you go to the
patriots you almost it's almost like a
rehab you come in you learn t you learn
teamwork you learn discipline you learn
unselfishness and i think we all had to
learn that to a certain degree whether
it's me randy moss corey dylan all the
guys that he that he brought in um
larry's centers all the great players
that he brought in and this is the same
thing with cam newton i think cam noon
has so much respect for coach belichick
first of all if he didn't have respect
for him he would have never signed up
but he has so much respect for coach
belichick and he understands that hey i
just want to fit in now he has positive
structure he knows he's going to have a
good defense he's got excellent coaching
he's got a great offensive coordinator
he's got all the pieces around him and
he's got a coach that's going to be
committed to running the football
committed to making sure that he's
protected they got some weapon some few
weapons around him but i do but but mike
at the end of the day i do believe that
they're going to try to establish the
run game
do the quick passing game take some
shots down the field and rely on that
defense and keep cam from getting
get hit a lot
you mentioned randy moss and that's one
of the ultimate gambles coach belichick
made by 2007 a lot of people thought
moss was washed up he had two mediocre
seasons in oakland after he was traded
by the vikings when he came into the
locker room was he already all in just
the fact that bill belichick showed
faith in him that he respects bill
belichick or or was there a requirement
a necessity by the veteran leadership to
make sure randy moss didn't do some of
the things that maybe he did earlier in
his career that got him in trouble you
know a guy that has a bad reputation if
he walks in the locker room i think it's
human nature to kind of just assume that
he's going to be like that but randy was
a he was a fantastic teammate he worked
his butt off you always saw him in the
training room you always saw him in the
weight room you always saw him just
doing positive things talking to people
randy was not a distraction and when he
was on the practice field he worked his
butt off i mean he was a perfect
teammate so anything that he had done in
his previous time whether it was oakland
or wherever he's been
minnesota that was all a race because he
was like the perfect teammate
now let's assume
that and i don't want to assume i'm not
rooting for this to happen but let's
explore the possibility
that cam either isn't healthy or he
can't beat out here at stidhum and it
just doesn't work and maybe before the
start of the season he gets released
what does this experience do to
undermine jared stidham if he ends up
being the week one starter that's in my
mind that's the risk they're taking here
that if it doesn't work they've set back
the development of the guy who's going
to end up taking over as the successor
to tom brady no i just i don't i don't
see it that way i see it as
you know when you're when you're faced
with adversity and competition let's see
what jarrod cinema has in him see if
he's able to step up see if he can
handle the pressure because ultimately
it's going to be a lot more pressure
planned for the new england patriots and
being the starting quarterback than just
playing against cam newton and competing
against him so if i'm jared stenham
i'm looking at as an opportunity to
compete against cam but not only just
compete against cam to go out here and
show my teammates what i'm truly capable
of doing and i think this is an
opportunity for him to learn from him to
sit back and and and understand that hey
there's always going to be guys that
they bring in you know you're never just
going to be the starting quarterback
they're going to always rotate guys in
because they're always looking for
bigger better and cheaper
and that's an excellent point you know
they always drafted quarterbacks when
tom brady was there the jimmy garoppolo
draft pick i think lit a fire under tom
brady that carried them to three more
super bowl wins and maybe this does
push jared stidham to a level he
otherwise wouldn't have been at maybe it
is the proverbial good problem to have
that both guys are playing at a high
level they have a hard time picking
between the two of them then they at
least know they've got two great
quarterbacks that they can move forward
with that's another excellent point it
really is a no-lose proposition
for bill belichick cam newton may be
great jared stidham may step up either
way
more numbers at the most important
position on the field as they try to
move forward without tom brady and think
about this to being a veteran you almost
you put so much pressure on yourself if
i was a veteran defensive player if i
was mccourty or stefan gilmore saying
hey guys we got to really step it up we
got basically a rookie coming in and
being a starting quarterback so there's
a certain level of concern that you
concern yourself with the offense even
as a as a defensive player but with cam
you're thinking okay i know what cam
gonna can do i know how physical he is i
know what he brings the energy the
emotion just everything like i would be
so excited and i was talking to a friend
yesterday and they said they heard the
mccourty brothers on their podcast and
as soon as they heard the news of cam
newton they just got really pumped up
and really excited like players in this
league they know who can make a
difference even though jared stenham
you know is their teammate they're
looking at him like you haven't done
anything you haven't proven yourself you
know like
we're heading toward the end of our
career we can't afford to go eight eight
nine and seven with cam newton we know
we have a chance to get back to that afc
championship game and make and make um
make a run yeah i can only imagine how
excited the players are it excites me
for the season and to bring it back full
circle rodney i i'm reminded there may
not be a season i hope there is this is
another reason to hope there is we want
to see cam newton on the field we want
to see what the patriots do post tom
brady and i can only hope that the
people who are in charge of the sport
have a good plan that not only covers
all of the bases and minimizes the
spread of the virus but helps the
players get to the point where they're
comfortable where they're confident
where they're not carrying around that
baggage you were talking about earlier
it won't happen mike the big concern i
have now rodney is whatever the league
is doing behind the curtain they're not
sharing it with enough people so that we
can get to the point where they don't
know what to do mike they don't know
what to do mike what can they do like
all the social distance and gap
guidelines you can do but once you enter
on that football field they all go out
the window like how i mean am i like the
only one that's seeing this like how
could you even think about having a
football season yes i want football i
want to talk every week and you know and
watch these games and see what's going
on but at the end of the day you can't
be safe and have a football season it's
still sweating it's still blood it's
still guys spitting on you guys getting
up off you shoving their sweaty forearms
in your throat guys talking smacking
spitting in your face directly it's no
way you're gonna be able to have
football without guys getting infected
that's just what it is
and here's what they're banking on
rodney
they're banking on their belief that the
virus primarily spreads indoors and
confined spaces bars and restaurants etc
and when you're in an open-air
environment or even in a dome where the
air system has the proper ventilation to
recirculate the air and and not enhance
the risk that they believe that when you
get in that setting it'll be okay well
that's one hell of a gamble that's one
hell of a roll of the dice and we're
gonna find out by the middle of
september whether or not that roll of
the dice works out
mike
i don't have anything else to say about
it because i just don't think we're
gonna have football we'll sit back and
see what happens but um
i think we're gonna be sitting here in
september looking at each other like wow
they just canceled the first four games
or i think it'd be crazy for them to
even try to go out there and play right
now
well here's hoping that they have a plan
and that they can make it work and that
they can make the players feel
comfortable and safe and rodney i i hope
it happens just because i want to talk
to you every week even if we aren't
sitting elbow to elbow we'll be putting
together the pre-game show before every
sunday night game so i i want football i
want to work with you i want to talk to
you again soon and maybe we'll do this
as we get closer to the season we have a
better idea of how things are going i
appreciate your time pal and we'll talk
to you again no doubt mike thanks man
it's always good to talk to you see you
later
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports